what wouldn't we do
to see the end of this virus the nhs
will get in touch when it's your turn to
get vaccinated
we knew so many people last year who are
not with us today
every little thing we do is a step
closer
to ending this virus and saving lives
there are many people in our community
who have been affected
everyone belongs to someone that's why
by simply taking this vaccination
could mean we are reunited with our
friends and families
the vaccine does not contain pork or any
material
or fetal or animal origin
it is completely halal taking the
vaccine is the best way
to boost our immunity against kovid this
can help protect you
and your loved ones there are no cases
of any significant
side effects amongst the millions of
people who have received the vaccine
at a time of darkness light often comes
from ordinary people
doing extraordinary things help save
life
by taking the vaccine we will soon be
able to live normal life
again hello
looking after others and saving our
community
is what we do it's how we've been
brought up
all we have to do is take the vaccine
thank you
just one simple step would once again
mean
that we can eat drink pray and hug
together
let's do the right thing
when it's my turn i will be taking the
vaccine
thank you when our turn comes
we will be taking the vaccine when my
turn comes
i will be taking the vaccine thank you
when my turn comes i will be taking the
vaccine
when it is my turn i will be taking the
vaccine
when my turn comes i'll be taking the
vaccine
when my turn comes i will be taking the
vaccine
thank you when my turn comes
i will be taking the vaccine
yes when my term comes i will be taking
the vaccine
when your turn comes please help save
lives
and take the vaccine thank you
it